pandemic is no excuse for new york
city's rising tide of violent crime
earlier this month four new yorkers were
shot dead in four incidents with 24
hours followed by a triple shooting in
times square
this is a 1980s level crime and the city
is getting used to it
with alarming uh alarming alerts uh a
large city
no it's not a large city alacrity
alacrity mayor de bla
bill de blasio answer to this is that
there's not much we can do
our entire lives return upside down a
global ban pandemic and a perfect storm
he says
so he hasn't acted with much urgency as
the murder rate rose
47 last year to a total of 468 people
killed and he has risen this year so far
by 17
this is just new york is what we're
talking about the rest of the world is
demonstrating
the obvious murders and other crimes
should be down during a pandemic right
look at the statistics here
so folks if you're listening to this new
york is up the rest of the world is down
in london the murder rate fell 16
during the pandemic in italy it dropped
by 14
in japan it dropped by 10 in france it
dropped by two percent
and even in mexico it dropped by half a
percent so what is wrong with us
not just new york but the country as a
whole with urban murder rates up 30
last year one answer is that compared to
europe and japan we have more guns
that's been a crisis for decades
yet it isn't new what is new in new york
and the rest of the country is that we
have effectively halted all preventative
policing we have also effectively
stopped all incarceration of suspects
and criminals short of murder
so what do you have to say to this
article by new york post what did it say
478 homicides 468 460 last year four
fights 47
okay so let me give you a number in 1993
there were two thousand two hundred
murders
in new york city two thousand two
hundred
in 1993 okay there was no [ __ ]
pandemic
this ain't about a pandemic this is
about
thugs being victimized this is about an
administration
de blasio's administration that has
handcuffed the cops
he took a billion dollars out of their
budget he took 600
plain clothes anti-crime cops off the
streets
when you work in plain clothes and i
work plain clothes as a cop
okay i'm not talking about narcotics if
you're in a plain clothes unit in new
york city
you're home can you explain what a plane
closes to folks who don't know what's
playing close
all right let me give you an example
times square okay where we first met the
first time i ever met you was in times
square
taxis yellow cabs everybody sees the
yellow cab in times square
well let me tell you an old trick i'll
give you some old trivia
if you see a cab and the number
on the cab in the middle letter was an r
and the last two numbers were the same
right on that cab
the three people that's riding in that
cab usually there'll be a driver and two
people in the back seat
those are cops okay they're in plain
clothes
they're in yellow cabs or they're in
plain clothes they're in unmarked cars
when you say they're playing clothes
they're dressed like you they're dressed
like normal yeah usually it's jeans
sneakers a vest
you know a jacket whatever the case may
be they they blend in they look like
anybody else
may have a beard not beard whatever
bottom line here's their job
their whole function in life is to look
for guns
and respond to what we call hot jobs
robbery in progress
shooting in progress shots fired
so you know somebody getting stabbed
whatever the case may be
their job is violence that's all their
job is
bill de blasio took 600 of them all of
them all the plainclothes units in new
york city
took them off the street 600 of them why
would he do something like that
he put him back in uniform why what's
the matter he said they were a threat to
the communities
in what way i don't know i i don't
what's the speculation though even the
speculation what is the speculation
my speculation is he's a [ __ ] that's my
speculation
very deep he's got to have some
justification for i don't know
he's got to look at stats i've got to
look at that i don't care
i don't know i'm asking well because
because it's like it's almost like it's
not fair people should know you're a cop
you shouldn't be hiding like you're not
a cop maybe that's what it is like
transparency right that's the whole
point of being undercover
here's here's the bottom line he takes a
billion dollars out of the budget
he takes 600 cops out of the streets
plainclothes unit cops their whole
function in life is to look for guns
takes them out and basically opens up
rikers lets people off rikers
institutes these laws with the city
council and the governor
where they're not going all the things
that pat just talked about right
you know they're not locking them up
they're letting them out they're not
holding them for bail
all that stuff so here's the bottom line
would you say the numbers
last year 660 460 468 468
2200 in 1993
okay between 1993
i left office in 2002 january 2002
we dropped that homicide number from
i walked out of office i think my number
was 671.
under mayor bloomberg we got it down to
371.
370. something like that
we had i had a 65 reduction in violent
crime
a 70 reduction in homicide
and an 80 reduction in homicide
in the black communities where the
violence was the highest so what did you
do during that time that they can be
doing today
what were some of the strategies and
tactics you guys used everything they're
not doing today which is what
basically um i'd have plain clothes cops
out there if i was
if i was the police commissioner today
right
i would go to the mayor and say i want
the billion dollars back
i want two new classes of 2000 each
in class i want 4 000 more cops than you
have
i had 55 000 people to work for me in
the nypd
41 000 of those who were uniform today
i think they're around 36 000 why
you have a bigger population in new york
city today than you did
in 20 years ago right why do they have
less cops working today
that's that's crazy and keep this in
mind
here's here's here's what people in in
in all those cities i mentioned earlier
whether it's atlanta baltimore these are
gorgeous some of these are gorgeous
cities right
nobody wants to live visit work
or go to a school in a place where
they're not safe
nobody wants to move into a neighborhood
where they got to put their kids to bed
in
bathtubs to protect them from gun
violence
that's the bottom line for every
percentage point
giuliani and i and the other
commissioners for every percentage point
we reduced
violence and homicide i could show you
increases
in economic development real estate
value
and tourism every percentage wow
it's up it's it is the bottom line you
know
a lot of the advocates in these
left-wing lunatics will get jump
on the on this totem pole saying this is
all socioeconomic
we need better jobs we need better
schools
we need whatever we need they'll talk
all this [ __ ]
right bottom line is you're not getting
none of that
you're not getting none you're not
getting better jobs you're not getting
better schools
as long as you have the highest violence
and crime
and the highest murder rate in your city
you're not getting none of that other
stuff why would somebody build a small
business over there
what risk am i going to take that's
exactly right
who's going to put a business there
who's going to create jobs
you think you think apple is going to
put a flagship
store on the on you know the south side
of uh chicago
no they're not the bottom line is
you have to fix the violence in the
murder ring
so let me continue because okay so
bernard to to be fair with the audience
you would consider yourself a republican
you would say you're a republican
yourself okay so you're a republican
new york post is a a
center-right newspaper a post is new
york time has left new york post is
right let's just kind of so i just read
to you stats
from new york post so somebody may say
and and usa today is
left but new york post usa today i'd say
center
i'd say usa today's center left i think
wall street journal today
is center center right yeah so new york
post
is right now next one npr what is npr
far certainly left far left right so
this next story i'm reading to is from
npr
massive one year rise and homicide rates
collided
with the pandemic in 2020 this is an npr
story and they have a data if you want
to pull up that link right there so they
can see it open for visual data guy
uh pull it up so they can see it at the
end of 2020 chicago police reported more
than 750 murders
okay this is 2020 during the pandemic a
jump of more than
50 percent compared to 2019 people were
out and about in 2019
people stayed home in 2020 how the hell
is murders
up 50 in chicago from 2020 to 2019. by
mid-december
l.a saw a rise of 30 over the previous
year with 330
322 homicides there were 437 homicides
in new york city
by december 20th nearly 40 percent
higher than previous year
new orleans-based uh based data
consultant jeff asher studied crime
rates in more than 50 cities and says
the crime spikes aren't just happening
in big cities
with the numbers of homicide spiking in
many places asher expects the final
statistic
for 2020 to tell a star uh startling
grim story
we're going to see historically the
largest one-year rise
in murder that we've ever seen
asher says it's been more than half a
century since the number since the
country saw a year to your
murder rate that jumped nearly 13
this is npr this isn't new york post
this is a wall street journal this is
npr and here's your answer
the answer is this has nothing to do
with the pandemic
in my opinion this has to do with every
one of those cities where
i where i was talking about chicago
included
you know chicago you're not allowed to
chase a bad guy
you know that right you know the mayor
said the mayor of chicago
um muriel bowser yeah says
you can't you have to get permission
from a supervisor
to run we're not talking [ __ ] car
chases
we're talking about running after
someone
you're not allowed to chase them unless
you get a supervisor's permission
okay that's the kind of [ __ ] that is
killing the police how does that even
mean
what is your job well i don't know guys
committing a crime can i get an approval
let me get a approval from management
management
you know ten minutes later the guys are
already coming you can't chase them in a
car you can't chase them on foot
you can't confront them you there's no
stop
question and frisk nobody wants that
anymore
basically they don't want you to do
anything that's the problem
that's the problem this is not about a
pandemic
this is about a change in the way
we deal with the criminal element well
here's what bloomberg comes out and
bloomberg we know the
uh left-wing uh side but they're pretty
reasonable i think when it comes down to
economics their center i like to get
bloomberg's facts but when it comes down
to it bloomberg ran as a democrat for
office and he's got a media empire this
is the story new york city's violent
crimes is up
so is the city's police budget would you
consider bloomberg a decent mayor for
new york city
he was he was okay fair enough so
protests calling to defund the police
have become a familiar side of new york
city but this year mayor de blasio gets
his way
one of america's most progressive cities
will actually send more
more dollars to the nypd than it did a
year ago this is a story from yesterday
the spy promises to
strip a billion dollars from city's law
enforcement budget
which gained national attention the wake
of george floyd's murder last year the
blast you slashed less than a half less
than half that as part of a broader
round of pandemic cuts and a spending sl
plan for fiscal 2020 to announce this
month
keeps police head head count and
operations intact
leaving any major shakeups of the force
up to whoever succeeds the term limit
mayor in january but now with shootings
in march
up 77 over last year let me say that one
more time
shootings in march of 2021 up 77
from last year and an influx of more
than four billion dollars
in federal stimulus funds available for
mental health at risk youth and other
social programs the notion of taking
police officers off the streets
has become less politically palatable
for the mayor and the dozens or so
candidates vying to replace them next in
new york is the largest police
department in the u.s
and has amongst the highest number of
officers per capita there were 436
officers per 100 000 in the city in 2019
compared
to 249 in la or 233 in houston according
to the fbi so
even de blasio is sitting there saying
maybe i screwed up what do you think
of course he screwed up and they all
know it all you had to do is look at
minneapolis minneapolis is the first one
that started this whole defunding
mess right they wanted to defund it they
wanted to diminish they wanted to
annihilate the police department
they defunded to an extent they also
wanted to bring in social services
instead of cops and all this
all this nonsense right well last month
or two months ago they had to basically
come out and say okay
yeah we screwed up we we gotta we gotta
refund
what we defunded we need 200
immediate cops back on the street we
need abc the bottom line is
the funding isn't going to work i don't
know what that what the mentality was
behind the funding
but it's not going to work your cr
everything i predicted
when minneapolis started the funding
everything i've said
everything i've i predicted has come
true
you defund you diminish their budget
you take away staffing you take away
resources
and here's here's the absurd thing you
take away their training
right so for the past 30 years
we've tried to train cops to do
everything under the sun
you want de-escalation you want verbal
judo
you want less lethal force you want to
give them
non-lethal force tools every single
thing that we've tried to give them to
make their job
better make them less confrontational
make
it work easier in communities well now
we're going to defund it we're going to
take all that [ __ ] back
really it makes it's absolutely nice
it makes no sense you know what i think
about like a soros imagine you're a cop
working for the guy what are you
thinking
what are you thinking you're thinking
they're morons no but but
i'm actually like literally
yes you're thinking they're morons but
what are you thinking are you sitting
there saying man am i gonna do a bang-up
job for this guy like
imagine that relationship like you know
this guy cannot stand you this guy wants
to get rid of you but he also knows he
needs you
but at the same time with the media he's
kind of have to we're talking about the
mayor right now
no no no i'm talking about yeah no no
hold on yeah hold on think about this
though
the city council members they have cops
they have drivers
the city officials the mayor he has a
protective detail that
probably ranges somewhere around 25
people
those cops that work for him despise him
right i know many of them i know many of
them
they despise him they can't stand him
and they can't stand them because he's
anti-cop he's anti-pd
he hates them he despises them how do
they work together on a daily basis but
they have a job to do
they have a job to do just imagine like
you're working for a guy that hates you
hates what you stand for but on a
personal level and
not interacting and i think you have the
city council in new york city
they they basically brutalize the nypd
on a daily basis
brutalize them on a daily basis how do
you interact with them
you have a job to do you go out and you
do your job so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye